Ticket type. Are they buying VIP or general admission?
>> Yep. Maybe number of tickets purchased, or I guess
you can infer that based off of ticket type. Yeah
>> Let's not make them do that.
>> Maybe the purchase source, cause they
care where most of their stuff's coming from?
>> Sure. Sure.
>> But yeah, you can keep modifying this, like, Save As, do a
couple different reports showing different data if
you had a lot of different fields.
>> Okay, so should I save this now?
>> So yeah, let's save it for now. but we want to
keep going.
>> So what we're doing here basically we're, our goal is
to make this, this you know gauge this little odometer looking thing.
>> Mm-hm. But, as long as we're making this report, we're just, kind
of, figuring out all of the information that might be relevant to convey.
>> Right.
>> Okay.